Matthew is with us in the santa barbara
california hey Matthew how are you I'm
doing great mr. mu how are you doing
better than I deserve sir how can I help
that's that's great to hear
I am a 18 and I've been following your
principles for a long time I'm fortunate
enough that I learned them from my
parents and you know I've never had a
credit card so I'm a little bit
concerned about how to go about renting
once I get out of college because I know
a lot of people won't rent to someone
with no credit score well there's two
types of landlords um there are ones
that are what we would call a corporate
landlord meaning an apartment complex
maybe that is owned by a real estate
investment trust and it's professionally
managed by a management company that
manages 27 apartment complexes all over
California or something like that those
kinds of people are going to be very
rigid and are going to expect to see
something like a credit score there that
manager of that apartment complex is not
allowed to think for themselves they're
dictated by their corporate office a set
of guidelines okay
you may not be able to rent there but
here's what the irony is I'm a
multimillionaire
and I couldn't rent there yeah I can buy
the complex but I couldn't rent there
you know that's the irony of this
ridiculous conversation so exactly so
that just means that I can't do business
with them there's some people I can't do
business with today because they won't
do something with me because I don't
have a FICO score and that's okay that's
okay that's their decision to run their
business but my decision is I'm not
going to go into debt just to get to
play footsie with them so but you can
rent to a landlord of some kind that is
able or willing to think for themselves
so let's kind of think about this
pretend for a second you were a landlord
all right and you had a guy come up I
mean the way you were raised let's say
you owned a house and you were renting
it and you had a guy come up who's 22
years old and wants to rent the house he
has a fabulous credit school
or to car payments a credit card payment
and to student loans okay or you have
another guy standing there who has no
credit score and no debt and let's
pretend they have us job making about
the same money well if I'm the landlord
I think the guy with no debt and no
credit score is a better as a better
chance of paying my rent because he
doesn't have payments coming out his
ears and so as a landlord that's able to
actually think and not just follow
corporate policy I'm more likely to rent
to you that I am your doofus friend
who's gone into debt to build up his
credit score does that make sense yeah
and and you don't even have to be like a
Dave Ramsey acolyte to think that way
you just are using good critical
thinking skills and going people that
don't have payments can pay better oh
hello you know I mean it's really dumb
right so yeah you know that's that's
what you got to do is so you you know
you knock on the door and this sweet
little couple comes out that's retired
and they rent have a rental house and
they're gonna show it to you and you go
I just graduate from college I don't
believe in borrowing money I don't have
a credit score but what that really
means to you is is that I'm able to pay
the bill because I don't have any
payments except this one so it's really
good for you that I don't have a credit
score and they go well yeah that kind of
makes sense and that kind of person will
rent to you all day long and they might
be a manager of an apartment complex
they might be just that sweet little
rental retired couple that has a couple
real properties or somebody like me you
know that has some buncha rental
properties and I just use critical
thinking skills I you know we do look at
people's credit but we do not rent based
on a lack of credit score unless it's
more we're more likely to rent based on
the lack of a credit score
there's a lack of a credit score at all
means you don't have debt it's the only
way to have no credit score and not
having that means you have money if you
have a job it's a pretty simple formula
for me that has a landlord so that's how
you look at it but yeah there's gonna be
some people turn you down but again they
turn me down and you know my net worth
is tens of millions of dollars and
that's just stupid you know it's just
the stupid world we live in